foreign
[Music]
welcome to the party we have a great
performance where you'll see
oops we are one hour away from the party
this is not a party this is cloud
networking session I'm Manisha Gupta
group product manager with Google Cloud
networking I have an incredible line of
speakers here with me to share the stage
and we'll make sure that the next 45
minutes are worth your time and we will
make sure that you get to the party on
time all right do I have everybody's
attention
okay awesome
so you've heard about cross Cloud
Network in the executive Keynotes
earlier in the week
so in this session uh we would like to
uh you know go a bit deeper into what
trust fund working is what cross Cloud
Network can do to transform how you
build applications how you deliver those
applications in a secure Manner and how
do you optimize experience for your end
users as you build and deliver these
Global applications
yeah
so here is our line of presenters I'm
joined with some of my esteemed
colleagues we have some partners and
customers as well uh who will join the
stage and they will talk about their
experiences uh working with us and
working with our Solutions
so let's just start with some context
and a lot of this is probably a recap of
uh you know what you heard in the
previous sessions we had an arc 201 this
morning where we where we talked about
some of the key challenges that we are
focusing on as we are thinking through
building this cross-cloud networking
platform right so a lot of you have
moved your applications to the cloud and
as you did that you built networking
solutions to connect your on-prem
networks to your Cloud Networks and as
you added more clouds these networking
Solutions became complex so these
networking solutions could be like
you've built collocations you've built
other Regional aggregation points or you
know whatever your choice of the
networking solution was
and from a security perspective a lot of
our customers they started with
deploying their on-prem firewalls into
these co-locations where they were doing
inter-cloud multi-cloud connectivity
and for the cloud workloads you know
there was a choice you could go with the
cloud native providers uh you know NATO
security controls or you could go
through the operational complexity of
deploying these third-party virtual
firewalls into your Cloud environments
so in either case uh networking was
challenging it was expensive and from a
security perspective you lost visibility
to your traffic as that traffic crossed
the cloud boundaries so this is one at
the core of you know some of the
problems that we looked at as we built
this platform
secondly when you know you want to
deliver these platforms now you have to
build your Global front ends so what
this does is it opens up a huge thread
surface for your applications which are
now exposed to internet-based threats
and which as we all know these threats
are increasing both in volume and
sophistication as the Bad actors out
there are increasingly using AI based
tools to create a new variant of the
thread every few minutes so how do we
make sure that you know as you are
delivering these applications over the
internet you are staying ahead of those
Bad actors in terms of securing your own
assets that are running in these public
Cloud environments
and finding your Workforce right so we
all are familiar with the growth in the
hybrid Workforce and we all know that a
lot of you have uh adopted best of breed
security providers in order to secure
access for those mobile users to your
Enterprise environments so while you
know the secure Services its solutions
they provide you with the best of lead
security
the one challenge that you know a lot of
customers have told us that they have
faced is around application experience
because the SSC providers are using
internet-based connectivity to connect
back into your Enterprise applications
after they have inspected the user
traffic coming into their environment
so if you kind of put all of this
together
what you see is
work of multiple
often built together by using solutions
from different vendors
it is very complex
you see inconsistent security it is very
hard to manage your security posture in
this kind of an environment and plus
you're also dealing with you know the
soaring costs of this network
yeah
so what if you could build your
applications by using any service that
met your needs in any environment that
you wanted so consider a scenario where
you built an application in Cloud a and
now you want to use bigquery or spanner
services to further enhance the
capability of that application or you
have your data on-prem and you want to
use that data to train your aim and
model running in gcp right what if you
could deliver these applications to your
Global users and you could turn on ML
based security out of the box
and what if you could do all of this
without impacting the application
experience for your end users and that
is really the goal for us as we thought
through building cross Cloud Network
platform
Global networking platform that offers
on-demand any to any connectivity to
bring these distributed applications
closer to each other
the ability to turn on ML based security
for any traffic flow app to app user to
app app to internet
and to provide that optimal experience
for your applications when those
application backends could be store
could be running in any Cloud
environment
so now let's take a deeper look of at
some of the key attributes of this
platform
so we understand that you
you might like to be logged in by good
enough vendor Security Solutions
like some of our other Cloud providers
are forcing you to do
our philosophy is a little different
we believe in giving flexibility and
choice to our customers to be able to
choose which security provider they want
to work with
and this is where we are investing very
heavily in developing very deep
Integrations with a broad partner
ecosystem so that we are able to offer
you these third-party services in Google
cloud in the same manner as we offer any
first party service
our latest addition to our partner
ecosystem are sassy providers Prisma
access from Palo Alto networks and
broadcom semantic secured web Gateway
solution where you can now turn on sassy
service within your own VPC in gcp as a
gcp native service without having to go
through complex routing changes to
enable these services for your
environment and we're extending the same
Integrations across our NG firewall
platform uh NG firewall Partners we have
existing Partnerships with sd-wan uh and
other uh industry leading routing
Partners so you have the flexibility to
bring in your traffic in any way using
our Partnerships turn on any third-party
firewall solution or uh SSC solution in
our environment
we also know that as you deploy your
Global front-ends for serving those
internet based applications you want to
bring in your choice of API security you
want to bring in your own bot management
solution or any other third-party
services for that matter for your own
custom needs your own compliance needs
security needs or any other business
needs and this is where we are
introducing data plane extensions into
our CDN and load balance of products
where you can either customize using
some simple lines of code if if that's
the way you want to go
or you can work with any of our third
party partners and insert those Services
very easily as you roll out this Global
front end with gcp
so quick quick question
who can tell me which gcp service
protected against the largest DDOS
attack that we have seen in the last 12
months
I'll give you a hint
the customer got got impacted with
broadcom
Cloud armor perfect thank you
Cloud armor was the first Cloud native
wav service to offer ml based DDOS
protection in the industry to protect
against zero day DDOS attacks and we
continue to invest in the space by
building more ml models to provide you
more coverage for different types of
attacks that you see you know when you
are deploying these applications and
delivering these applications over the
internet
but we also know that security is the
best of breed market and there are
existing Pure Play vendors who have
invested years and years in building
that threat until and building bringing
that threat Intel into their products
and into their Solutions
so we are also investing in partnering
with the market leaders to bring in
their services into our environment as a
gcp native service
NG firewall service that we announced
this week is a classic example of our
partnership with Palo Alto networks
where we brought in their Advanced
threat protection as a native service in
gcp within our Cloud distributed Cloud
firewall stack
the other cool um the other cool you
know aspect of our security
capability as part of this platform is
something that the security teams
struggle with a lot in terms of
compliance auditing and overall managing
and monitoring the network security
posture
so with all these distributed uh this
with all these disjointed tools and uh
products it's very very hard for a
security uh a security team to know what
the security posture is of this hybrid
environment so with our odd level
policies non-security teams can
Monitor and maintain the network
security posture that is acceptable to
your organization for your line of
business and they can audit uh and they
can uh you know plan for conformance to
certain
um standards that your business requires
through our odd level policies and our
policy different constructs and they can
do so at scale because we do not require
security teams to be requiring routing
design changes to your network if you
have to insert something simple as a
layer 4 or layer 7 firewall in your
traffic so any security control that you
want to turn on in gcp Cloud you can do
that with the security policy without
having to ever rethink about your
network design
and while you do all of this
you can be assured that it would not
impact the experience of your
applications that could be running in
different environments so cross Cloud
networks makes Google's Planet scale
backbone available for you to use and
build your Enterprise Network on top of
that
and with our extensive peerings with our
isps SAS vendors our broadest presence
across more than 200 countries and
territories we provide the best
application experience for any
application that you're hosting in
Google cloud or in any other environment
with optimal application experience
and Google's intelligent routing will
guarantee the best path to steer your
traffic anywhere in your environment
so with cross Cloud Network you can
easily consume any gcp service to build
your distributed applications anywhere
and we provide you a very scalable
service based networking architecture to
build these applications
you can deliver your distributed
applications with ML based security
turned on by default with a cloud armor
service
and you can standardize on your security
provider for Workforce security be it
SSC or any other stack that you that you
wish to use to secure all your hybrid
Workforce and at the same time
optimizing the experience for your
private applications
cross Cloud network is real
and our customers are already using it
to accelerate their business goals
so I would like to invite Tom and Victor
to tell us more about how Priceline is
using cross Cloud Network to resolve
some of these challenges and we'll go
through the details
thank you Manisha
so good afternoon thanks for joining us
um that was a great review of the Cross
Cloud Network I have the privilege of
sharing the stage here with Tom today
Tom is a principal network engineer at
Priceline and Tom has a lot of
experience building networks and has
been on a journey to actually take
Priceline into cloud in the last few
years Tom you want to tell us a little
bit about Priceline yeah thanks Victor
hi everybody thanks for coming out
tonight Priceline is an online travel
agency who's been in business for the
last 25 years we help our customers
experience the moments that matter
through great deals on hotels flights
rental cars vacation packages and more
thanks thanks Tom so we're going to look
in more detail at the cross Cloud
Network and we're going to look mainly
at three use cases we're going to look
at building distributed applications as
Manisha alluded to we're looking at
basically combining the best of any
resources you may have in any of these
different networks that we're
interconnecting and then we'll talk a
little bit about how we actually take
those distributed applications and
deliver them out on the internet and
last but not the least what we do to
actually secure hybrid Workforce
so with that in mind let's go into the
distributed application and how we
assemble this so at the foundation of
delivering these distributed
applications is connectivity so the
first thing that we need to optimize is
how we actually provide that
connectivity and we're evolving our
interconnect product to give you
cross-cloud interconnect which is
basically a point-to-point connection
directly between Cloud providers so you
don't have to manage a router in a
collocation and hop through that router
to interconnect Cloud providers we go
back to back it's a fully managed
delivery system where you can actually
get a letter of authorization from the
peer provider and Google Cloud will take
care of all of all the um
all the setup for you now why is this
important and why is this relevant well
first we want to simplify what you're
doing in those collocations but more
importantly by going back to back you
can enable maxic and now you get privacy
that you didn't have before in these
connections because you're bypassing
these uh routers in the way your latency
could presumably be lower but what
really makes it lower is the fact that
there's a global footprint of
collocations where you can actually
create these connections and you can
create connections where you really need
them where they really are going to
reduce your latency and lastly we can
guarantee
99.99 availability for your services so
when you look at that whole combination
you're now looking at a very trustworthy
set of connections that start making
this multi-network network network
s behave as if it was one backbone and
in one backbone you can do things that
you couldn't do before now you've got
latency considerations that that
prevented you from doing things before
that you can actually overcome privacy
and so forth so
that's the very heart of this now once
you have this available your developers
are going to want to create services on
top of this and one of the key tools is
load balancing we've extended our load
balancing to actually include hybrid
resources resources that are in other
clouds by using what we call the Hybrid
next the Hybrid next actually can
include in the back ends of the load
balancers basically resources on all of
these other clouds now
that is not sufficient because we want
to make this Global so we also have
introduced the global backends which
means our backends can now cut across a
multitude of regions so all the benefits
of actually Health checking on the
resources are now extended to resources
that are in other clouds over these fast
links so now it starts looking like
you've actually expanded the scope of
your cloud
all in one and lastly you're going to
have to have access to private services
or to apis in general right and we want
to do that in a private manner we don't
want to go out to the internet to get to
these services that we've gone through
all the work to actually create this
network so with PSE you can actually
create a private presence for all these
services and access the services from
wherever you may be in this Federation
of networks whether it's from on-prem
another cloud provider or natively from
Google Cloud
now once you've assembled your services
you can also choose to publish them for
consumption by other organizations and
you can basically attach PSC as a front
end to the applications that you've
created with resources that are
distributed across multiple clouds
so very interested to hear how Priceline
can leverage some of these tools
yeah definitely so Priceline started our
Cloud Journey several years ago and you
know right away we saw the benefit of
leveraging the interconnect product line
to help us scale
um our infrastructure building a secure
hybrid Cloud architecture right
Transforming Our workloads with the
power of Google Cloud's technology
attached to our data centers I'm excited
to hear that you're including the cross
Cloud connectivity in that piece we have
workloads and other clouds that's
challenging to manage that connectivity
and I believe we'll be able to leverage
that in
a ton of use cases as soon as I started
uh start my way back home the benefits
of encryption with maxic is something
that we've had to do internally for
different Regulatory and compliance
reasons we handle a lot of personal data
and payment data and go through a number
of regulatory and compliance exercises
so definitely we'll see the benefit of
that my infosec team I'm sure is going
to be excited to hear that that's a
possibility for us with Google cloud and
obviously you know the predictable
latency and dynamic scaling of that
Network fabric is very important you
know
right away from the beginning of our
migration we had large-scale data
transfers and how do I enable teams to
start transforming their workloads right
away and being able to meet that scaling
without having to invest a lot of time
and energy and
um
build new relations with a whole bunch
of different partners that'll really
enable us to continue to flex out our
infrastructure so go to your point three
here PSC and even PSA has been huge in
our Ai and ml enablement for Priceline
we're
you know right now building out a ton of
generative AI features including a
chatbot where you just brought to Market
called Penny which will help customers
transform their travel book experience
giving them ways to personalize their
travel experience and help them find
great discounts so that's been really
awesome it's been obviously a huge topic
throughout the past couple of days so
it's been you know really exciting being
able to leverage things like vertex Ai
and Bard to help us with internal search
for
the uh crazy amount of documentation and
the uh you know separated data sets is
also very important so
um
you know the the combination of the
cross-cloud interconnect the PSC being
able to connect my data sets and other
clouds is a really powerful story
um continuing with those themes of
resilience and performance powering all
of that I think it's going to provide a
great value to us and your other
customers
so we can go into our next slide here we
can talk a little bit about I'm excited
about Penny yeah it's very cool I want
to I want to see that we
probably need Penny to push on this by
the way
here we go yeah absolutely
um
so you know Victor and I have been
talking about this for a while and
thought it would be a great idea to give
you uh some understanding of the
architecture at Priceline we have a
multi-regional architecture with
vpcs and uh you know we operate out of
several regions
um you know part of a great part of that
architecture includes the load balancers
with global access being able to make
sure that our workloads are available
where we need them to be leveraging the
internal health checks and smart Network
routing to complement the application
routing has been critical to the way we
operate our our stack it's definitely a
hugely important part of our disaster
recovery and business continuity
workflow as well we're able to shift
traffic in and out of regions take
regions in and out of service
and the global back end solution that
Victor mentioned in the previous slide
will be a great complement to that now
not only do I have front ends that are
globally available but now I can choose
back ends from other Cloud providers and
other regions and how do I tie those
things in where it makes the most sense
you know gives me great flexibility
again with the ability to rely on the
resiliency and the health checks that
are coming with the cross-cloud
networking solution so it'll continue to
help us accelerate in our migrations and
integration into Google cloud and gives
us new ways to think about Dr and BC
instead of failing at a region level I
can probably fail to service levels I
can probably put workloads in other
places that would you know maybe be more
optimal for our product stack or for our
customer experience so a lot of great
flexibility a lot of flexibility yeah
yeah I'm looking forward to working on
this with you so
without security nothing happens right
no no plane is left off the ground
without securing it and and this is no
different right so Malaysia shared with
you a little bit of what we're doing in
terms of integrating natively fully
functional uh firewall Stacks so our our
Cloud firewall is evolving to basically
be
a fully uh fully featured Next
Generation firewall is actually powered
by our partners Palo Alto in the back
end so it's a Palo Alto firewall that is
actually plumped for you just like we
Plumb your native Cloud firewall so you
don't really see it you set your policy
and the policy will apply to the
workloads that are involved right so
that's the kind of cloud model that we
want for these for these firewalls and
as as you look at this we're basically
bringing a ton of networks all together
and there's perimeter firewalls at the
edges of those networks right so how are
we going to do this in a practical
manner so this is a tool that comes into
play to actually allow you to do this in
a way that is actually Cloud friendly
versus having to do a lot of PBR and
static routes and all sorts of really
fun stuff when you do it once but the
second time around it you don't want to
do it anymore right so so that comes
with its own
policy language and we extend our Cloud
firewall policy to actually allow you to
do next Generation firewalling there and
we understand that you probably have a
big investment in your your existing
policy language and tooling and
Integrations and so forth so for you to
bring all that over and still get the
benefits of that native Plumbing We have
basically the Network Services
integration manager or affectionately
known as nsip and nsim allows you to
basically bring bring your own firewalls
there is a series of partners that
actually participate in this program and
the firewall will be discovered all the
resources in Cloud will be actually
built for you and you you are left with
the things that you care about the life
cycle management of the software on your
firewalls all the policies on your
firewalls and the integration with your
systems so this this is basically how
we're planning on securing all the
traffic to and from the workloads in in
the distributed app Tom what do you
think do you think this is useful for
you guys yeah definitely I mean this is
going to be I think a pretty powerful
shift in traffic inspection and defense
for my workloads
um you know at next there's been a lot
of Buzz around the ngfw
um and I definitely see that it has a
place in our architecture
um there are seven inspection is
important for some of my most secure
workloads as well as the AI driven
threat intelligence that comes with a
platform like Palo Alto the URL
filtering DNS security you know many
great options and features available
there and to your point uh you know this
becomes more than a workload Protection
Service you're talking about being able
to build perimeters in the cloud that
makes sense Priceline manages a lot of
network perimeters and this gives me an
opportunity to consider centralizing
some of that making my life a little bit
easier and more uniform as far as how do
I allow things to talk to my cloud and
what can I do to
um continue to build that security
posture that makes the most sense to how
we're developing our tools you know and
then you made another great Point taking
advantage of existing tooling and the
Investments That companies have made in
you know deploying your own Palos and uh
being able to Leverage The apis that the
vendor exposes to build Automation and
tooling and making you know operations a
lot easier is definitely critical so
simplified management reducing our
complexity they're all powerful stories
to to tell here fantastic so
um tell me a little bit about how you do
it today yeah so we've we've had some
scars
um yeah so we leveraged the native
firewall in Google and that's been
awesome allowing us to adopt micro
segmentation and transform the way we do
a lot of our policies but we did this we
saw that there was value in bringing a
next-gen firewall to Google and deployed
virtual Palos and it's been a huge step
in our security posture
we identified the need for URL filtering
and that threat analysis and mitigation
that we talked about but it didn't come
without complexity right there's a lot
to manage when you do something like
this there's
routing and multiple vendors load
balancers lots of different pieces that
you have to manage on top of the
lifestyle life cycle of the virtual
Appliance right there's firmware to
manage and patching and you know making
sure that you have all of your security
policies and posture and configuration
lined up
so looking forward to see how that gets
simplified with next-gen firewall and
glad to see that the Google Cloud team
has provided a way for customers to move
forward on this in the interim fantastic
well it's a journey right so we we
protect workloads today and as we move
forward that Transit traffic will also
be natively natively enforced
so I'm going to shift gears to the
Second Use case so we talked about
delivering the application on the
internet and what we're going to do for
that so now that we've built this
network and it has all the bandwidth
that it has you got the latency under
control you could see that you may have
web applications that are in different
Cloud providers or maybe on-prem and
you're probably running a dedicated
front end for each one of these and you
you could conceivably think well what if
I brought it all under one umbrella and
that's exactly what we are opening the
opportunity for you to do so the global
front end is at its heart has the global
application load balancer the global
application load balancer is distributed
worldwide and it can advertise a single
unicast IP address for your application
out of dozens of different pops around
the world
the result of that is that you can get
to your application without playing any
tricks on DNS Geo localization
you have one IP address that is valid
across the world and shortest path
routing is actually going to get you to
the front end in the pop that is closest
to you so we optimized that leg of the
of the connection with just standard
routing mechanisms and then once you're
on the global load balancer that Global
load balancer is actually running health
checks on all of these services not just
to the different Cloud providers but to
the different regions on the different
Cloud providers and on-prem Facilities
so you have full knowledge of what the
best place is to actually serve that
application from
so that's the second leg optimized so
now you've got the optimal path to the
better place to to service the
application from and if you have static
content which we all do then we offload
that to the cloud CDN that is co-located
with these load balancers
so that optimizes your traffic the next
thing that we need is basically security
Manisha talked a little bit about this
and how we have a an extensible
framework where you can actually
grow grow your security stack and
customize it right so the load balancers
are based on Envoy proxy infrastructure
and the Android proxy infrastructure
allows to use service extensions and we
start with Waf services and distributed
denial of service attack protection but
now you have an open environment where
you can actually include bot protections
and API protection so
pretty powerful any thoughts on how you
could benefit from this so oh absolutely
I mean the Google Cloud load balancer
and Cloud armor are critical to the way
we deliver our products to customers
glad to see that the cross Cloud
networking is integrated into this as
part of the full picture being able
again to attach backends that are in
other Cloud providers and surface them
through a unified front end with Google
Cloud that will continue to accelerate
opportunity to integrate Services while
maintaining the benefits of the gclb
right that anycast iping and the
application routing features as well as
the layers of security enhancements
being able to leverage Cloud armor with
its ml enhancements as well as the
system extensions I think we'll be
something that we'll definitely want to
look into
you know
providing DDOS protection on-prem and in
other networks can be complicated and
I'm hoping that this will be a great way
to to do that with a lot less complexity
so I'm sure my SRE team will love to
hear about all of this they're going to
have plenty of ideas about how we can
start bringing some of this into our
product portfolio well we'll for sure go
talk to the sret yeah
right right after this so
so secure securing
securing access from the internet super
important but also we have all our
employees are now basically living the
internet right so the story has changed
from uh it's I go to work I'm on a
private Network I go home and if I want
to do some work I have to VPN into the
private Network so no matter what we
were keeping people on the private
Network that all changed and it
accelerated with covet where the
internet was the the network right and
as a consequence the risk profile of of
our our employees our users basically
changed and what the security industry
has done is basically they've enhanced
the security Stacks to include features
that Control Data leaks can include
other features that are relevant to the
to the public access of all of these
resources and basically the the stack
that resulted is what is known as the
secure service edge stack or SSC
and those Stacks have traditionally been
deployed in their own Pops in their own
locations on on the internet reachable
over the internet but they are also
separate from the data center so if
you're accessing a private application
those tags after processing and securing
everything have to basically encrypt the
traffic and tunnel it back and there is
a performance cost to that encryption in
that tunneling there's also performance
cost to that detour that we take so what
we're doing is basically bringing those
secure Services Edge Stacks with with
partners and bringing them into Google
right some of them already run on Google
Cloud but but what's new here is that
the traffic that comes off this security
stack is now natively in your VPC it's
part of your network so there is no
requirement for encryption you're
basically on a on a fast connection
native in Cloud
and now you can actually treat it in the
same way as you treat the native
firewalling right so so this gives us a
lot of advantages in terms of
performance of applications that
actually are accessed from the public
network also for users that are in need
to access SAS applications that are out
on the internet we'll go through this
stack as well so now you have the
flexibility to stitch based on policy
the traffic through these services and
without having to create any external
complicated networks and this is a key
part that I would like your uh your
thoughts Tom on what your journey has
been like in actually simplifying the
network that you had to build before
and bringing that into a network that is
Consolidated or simplified yeah
definitely and you know as you stated
the conditions with covid and migrating
to a hybrid Workforce we had to rethink
how we were performing and providing VPN
services for our our staff right we went
through a major Wan consolidation over
the past year where we adopted
Prisma access as part of that solution
um because you know managing VPN
head-ins and Transit networking while
still maintaining a high quality user
experiences obviously comes with a lot
of challenges especially as that
Workforce stretches and starts to become
International so we wanted to adopt the
SSE for benefits of reduction in
managing that Hardware reduction and
Route complexity being able to leverage
the features of malware protection and
URL filtering and data security as well
as being able to took all of this into
our Cloud Network fabric it made a ton
of sense right so the journey that we're
looking forward to as the secure
Services Edge is brought into Google
we'll be focused on continuing to
simplify that management I can consider
dropping some of that Transit networking
and simplifying that so that my sites
and my users connect directly to my
prism Edge within Google
you know that comes again with the
benefits you stated being able to drop
lots of ipsec tunnels so that I can take
it full advantage of the line rate
speeds and being able to deeper
integrate those Services into my cloud
stack so I can surface workloads that my
users need to access every day in a
again a predictable latency experience
with all of that bandwidth there's a lot
of parts there that you know definitely
make sense as well as continuing to
expose more PSC and Google API driven
services so that we can continue to
build cool new features for our products
fantastic so do you think you'll miss
your old Network
uh
we'll see let's see now how about
um
experience application experience do you
see this actually improving it or
how how do you see it yeah absolutely so
um you know I think this is a a good
summary of being able to bring all of
these cross-cloud networking Solutions
together right so the hybrid Workforce
Now gets to benefit from the cross-cloud
uh interconnected Network architecture
being able to have the performance
benefits from that the connectivity into
other clouds workload availability being
able to access the workloads I need them
to wherever they might be as well as
move them around with whatever makes
sense in my stack with the global back
end and again the global access product
uh the performance benefits of the
secure Services Edge being regionally
available all of my distributed
International Workforce will connect to
Pops that make the most sense for them I
don't have to back all traffic across
oceans and
give you know peculiar localization uh
artifacts as people are accessing things
over the Internet
um you know it'll be closer to them so
that I'll translates into a better
experience for them as well as the rich
SAS pairing fabric that Google Cloud
provides right I have a lot of SAS
Solutions in my network architecture
today and being able to continue to
extend those benefits as a part of that
is great and then again we're talking a
lot about how do we make our lives
easier we've all managed Hardware we've
all managed life cycle of those
appliances this gives us the ability to
focus on delivering features and focus
on how do we continue to improve
products instead of just managing
hardware and Transit fantastic well
thank you so much Tom for all those
wonderful insights none of this would
happen without strong Partnerships and
to tell us a little more about those
Partnerships I'm going to invite anupam
and Anup to the stage so that they can
tell you all about the great Palo Alto
and Google Cloud partnership thank you
thanks
good afternoon
can you hear me yeah perfect
that was a very crisp articulation of
the value proposition of cross law
Network
so I'm going to invite
anupam for and thank him for being here
with us to share some of the his
thoughts on our journey together so
before that I would really like to thank
Palo Alto
who has been a long time customer and
partner of Google Cloud
anupam we have known each other for more
than 10 years now first as friends then
as colleagues and now as partners
representing two industry leaders
our partnership I don't believe has been
stronger ever before
you heard about the cloud ngfw that we
launched as part of this partnership
delivering 20 times the efficacy that
other similar Solutions in the market
have
as the product leader for Prisma sassy
what do you think are the synergies
between Google cloud and Palo Alto yeah
first of all thank you for having me uh
great to be here Tom great articulation
of prismaccess thank you uh look Prisma
access is Palo alto's Cloud level Sashi
solution which protects all users and
all applications with a consistent
security and policy stack all users
means hybrid could be remote could be
Branch application could be private
public SAS infrastructure as a service
and doing that with a single policy and
a single security stack
and what we're doing is we are providing
security and access without compromising
on security or access and the way that
is done is we focus on our core
competency of just security and leverage
Google for its hyperscaler
uh the whole idea is to get the traffic
we host our service on Google Cloud
we get to Google Cloud as fast as
possible as close to the user inspect
the traffic use Google's premium
backbone to get as close to the
application as possible
and then egress out and what that does
is it allows us to have a security
processing SLE of less than 10
milliseconds and that's really possible
by bringing principal access and Google
Cloud together
is real it's
literally about 16 months back there was
a fiber cut in Greece which caused a
huge impact it had Ripple effects from
Europe all the way to Australia
and a lot of SSC vendors that build the
data centers and fibers Bond their own
are actually an outage lasting hours
in our case our outage was less than six
seconds which means it was not
perceptible to the user and that was
done because we were leveraging Google's
hyperscaler Google saw the fiber cut
they moved to a different path and there
was no impact to our Pro to our service
that's the power of Google and Palo Alto
coming together to offer this Cloud
sassy solution didn't you have a Blog on
that yes I did I did absolutely and I
think that was the time time when
returned to office was becoming a thing
Anup and I got back at Palo Alto and we
were discussing look this Cloud thing is
real like Victor was saying everything
is in the cloud people are working from
anywhere a lot of customers are using
multi-cloud Solutions
how do we take advantage of this
infection point multi-cloud and hybrid
Workforce to provide a more
differentiated solution for the customer
do you remember that conversation
absolutely
as you heard earlier the on-prem to
Cloud migration is almost behind us
gen AI is changing the way our customers
are thinking about innovating into the
future
applications and data are distributed
with cross cloud dependencies
customers are Global and the workforce
is hybrid
by bringing two solutions like Prisma
access and Google's Planet scale Network
together we are able to now offer a
solution that is extremely difficult to
replicate in the industry
with cross Cloud Network solution for
hybrid Workforce we have a solution that
allows our customers to consolidate the
bespoke networks
have
consistent best of breed security
and enhanced application experience all
together
but I don't believe this is it anupam we
have to continue down this journey and
if I were guessing we will be
brainstorming again for the next wave of
innovation and I have a feeling that it
has got to do with something to do with
AI and co-pilots something that your CEO
nikesh is very hot on and I promise next
time I will host in Google oh that's
awesome two things Cafe food is good and
I need to have that rivet match with you
guys in cricket we lost the last round
look uh
Char GPT was as a phenomena that got
Unleashed on the world this year and
it's just not the good guys that are
using charge GPT we are seeing large
language models being adopted by Bad
actors to provide provide vulnerability
attacks and malware and they are trying
to use all those artificial intelligence
to create new attacks
and for security vendors to stay ahead
we got to understand interpret those
attacks and provide the right protection
for that and this is where the power of
Palo Alto security stack
and the data that we get from our
security stack because of our points of
presence across multiple thousands of
customers and Google Cloud's AI
strengths comes to play when you put
both of these together now what you can
do is you use that data to really
understand and that that data is just
not the data that you're coming from
your customers the data that you also
coming from the dark web and really use
that data to understand what are the new
security threats and vulnerabilities
that can be launched against you and
build use that to build the next
generation of defense for that even
before those threats get launched I
think that's the next Frontier for us to
come together and really keep one step
ahead of the bad guys like we always
have been thank you anupam very well
said uh I'm sure we'll see you all again
next year speaking about what we are
introducing in AI right thank you
awesome so let me wrap this up really
quickly so as a summary cross Cloud
network is here it is real and this
solution offers up to 35 percentage
improved application experience up to 40
percentage lower TCO for not having to
manage your own networks that provide
the cross Cloud connectivity and last
but not the least security is built in
and it is best of breed
foreign
Network you have a open platform uh with
best of breed security that is built in
that provides any to any connectivity
with high performance uh underlying
Network it makes the access to Google's
Premium One first party services like
vertex AI spanner gke extremely simple
and efficient so with that we're going
to conclude the session uh we have run
out of time for Q a but we'll be here if
you have any questions we'll take it
just beside the stage here thank you
thank you